ukraine and russia have carried out
their biggest prisoner swap since the
war began in february
144 ukrainian soldiers were freed
including 95 from the azov regiment that
defended mariupol's steel factory the
head of the self-proclaimed donetsk
people's republic which is backed by
russia said it had secured the release
of the same number including soldiers
from the russian army
all right well let's bring in dw
correspondent emmanuel shaz who is in
the ukrainian port city of odessa
emmanuel good to see you can you tell us
more
about this prisoner swap
yes pablo indeed this is the biggest
prisoner swap since the beginning
of the war on february 24th this is not
the first time we've seen
every now and then a dozen prisoners
exchange you know those numbers those
figures but never
144 according to our information this is
an equal number on both sides so 144
ukrainian
personnel not only soldiers but also
police officers borders officer and on
the on the russian side
as well russian soldiers and pro
separatists soldiers from eastern
ukraine also in the number of 144
on the ukrainian side it is significant
because
95 of those uh prisoners which have been
returned to ukraine fought in mariupol
steel plant and among them 43 were
fighters from the other battalion it's a
regiment pardon it was a regiment that
was there used to be a paralympic
paramilitary regiment which joined the
ukrainian armed forces a few years ago
it has the status here of a heroic
regiment but the russian
army said that it is neo-nazi soldiers
and because of that they say they want
to try they wanted to try those saudis
so it's big news here in ukraine that
those saudis are coming back
unfortunately uh most of them are
civilly
severely injured after the fighting they
have bullet wounds
burns also fractures so they are in a
quite a dire state now
emmanuel you talked with the friends and
family of one prisoner from morocco
who's being held by the russians for
fighting with the ukrainians in mariupol
can you give us some more details about
his case
yes the case of ibrahim sadhu along with
that of two britons with whom he had
surrendered in april for mariupol is
quite interesting because they are the
first three foreign fighters to be tried
by a court led by prosecutors so a court
that is not internationally recognized
perhaps let's have a look up at his
story
brahim sadhun left for the front lines
with his childhood teddy bears trapped
to his military kit
he came to ukraine from morocco to study
aerospacial sciences but last november
swapped his student visa for a military
one
and joined the army much to the surprise
of his friends
i was against that and one of the main
arguments he gave me was the fact that
he's kind of feeling useless so he wants
to do something useful and find himself
but brahim didn't serve long he fought
in mariupol and surrendered to russian
forces along with over a thousand fellow
servicemen mid-april but the separatist
authorities didn't treat him like a
ukrainian prisoner of war they argued he
was a foreign mercenary and put him on
trial along with two britons
they are the first foreign fighters to
be tried since the beginning of the war
at the beginning of june all three were
sentenced to death
ukrainian authorities and ngos both
reject this verdict as a separatist
caught in donbass is not recognized by
kiev or by the international community
it's
propaganda's
show and
in this case first of all the
issue on the
institution so-called court
that provided this verdict
the
death
sentence is
not
applicable and available
on ukrainian territory we are on
ukrainian territory so we consider it
like the action of terrorist
organization and it's pure terrorist act
that should be condemned and uh
severally punished on international and
national level we are dealing with the
big terrorist group supported by
terrorist state for ibrahim's family the
trial and death sentence came as a shock
and they say they haven't received any
help from the moroccan authorities so
far
the moment when i seen the video of his
captivity i tried to contact the
moroccan embassy and where i am right
now and they literally were like what do
you expect us to do
i tried to reach many other uh
authorities and sadly everything was
silent
i feel like they're just like scared to
talk about it maybe
like
literally just trying to keep it down
like he doesn't exist at all
just like his family ibrahim's friends
feel very alone in trying to help him
out of this situation
they have launched a social media
campaign and canvassed all around the
city we saw that these are very
effective and we put a qr code on them
because people started texting us on the
social media campaign that we started
say for him they're like we sell those
clusters around the city and what can we
do to help
ibrahim's friend and family put what
hope they have in the support they get
from the public
while the separatists remain in charge
in donbass that's about the only thing
they can do
and the european court of human rights
actually seized the case and said it
wanted it took step towards russia to
ensure that the death sentence
wouldn't be carried out for ibrahim
sadhun and the two britons who were
sentenced to death along with him
well emmanuel russian missiles continue
to rain down on ukraine but does
moscow's main focus remain in the
donbass region
it definitely does uh fighting is very
intense in donbass especially around the
city of lizzie chanska the russian
troops are trying to cut to
take possession of the highway leading
to the nearby city of bhagmot
but indeed as indiscriminate shelling
all over ukraine even last night here in
odessa there were two alerts and
ukrainian
defense forces reported six missiles
that fell on the region one being
intercepted just here above the city of
odessa